[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا بدات مشاهدينا
انطلاقه هذا الموكب الذي يقل الملك تشارلز
الثالث رفقه قرينته الملكه كاملا من قصر
باكنج هام كما نشاهد في هذه الصور وهو
يستقل
عربه اليوبيل الماسي والتي كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل بانها استخدمت لاول مره عام 2014
وكما نشاهد تجرها سته خيول هذا الموكب
للملك تشارلز الثالث سيسير في جاده ذا مول
الطويله حتى ميدان الطرف الاذر سيعبر
الوايت بعد ذلك حي الوزارات قبل ان يصل
الى الكنيسه اذا هذه صور مباشره ننقلها
لكم من العاصمه البريطانيه لندن موكب
الملك تشارلز الثالث ينطلق من قصر
باكينغهام بالاتجاه الى كنيسه ويست مونستر
كنا قد تابعنا اليوم ايضا واياكم مشاهدينا
توافد حشود من بريطانيا ومن شتى حتى انحاء
العالم الى لندن لمتابعه هذا التتويج
للملك تشارلز الثالث الذي يتجه بهذه
اللحظات هو وقرينته الملكه كامل من قصر
باكينغهام الى كنيسه
مونستر تشيلسي حكم بريطانيا خلفا لوالدته
الملكه اليزابيث التي توفيت في سبتمبر
الماضي
يصبح اذن في سن الرابعه والسبعين اكبر ملك
بريطاني يضع على راسه تاج سانت ادوارد
المصنوع قبل 360 عاما عندما يجلس طبعا على
كرسي العرش الذي يعود الى القرن الرابع
عشر في كنيسه
ر في لندن كل ذلك سيحدث امام امراه من
طبعا مئات الرؤساء رؤساء الدول وكبار
الشخصيات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات